[موسيقى]
مساء الخير سؤال قديم يتجدد لماذا كل هذا
الدعم الامريكي المطلق الاعمى لاسرائيل
رغم انه يضر بمصالحها اي رغم ان هذا الدعم
يضر بالمصالح الامريكيه حقيقه الامر هناك
جدل قديم
في الولايات المتحده وبين المهتمين
بالسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه خلاصته هل
اسرائيل اصل مفيد لامريكا ام انها عبء
عليها انصار اسرائيل ومنهم الرئيس
الامريكي الحالي جو بايدن يعتقدون ان
اسرائيل احد عناصر القوه للولايات
المتحده بايدن هو من يكرر دائما منذ العام
1986 لو لم تكن هناك اسرائيل لكان على
امريكا ان تخترع اسرائيل لحمايه مصالحها
في المنطقه هذا فريق لكن هناك فريق ثاني
يرى ان اسرائيل عبء على الولايات المتحده
وان امريكا في حقيقه الامر كما وصفها حميد
جول رئيس المخابرات الباكستانيه الاسبق لم
تعد الا عملاقا تجره اسرائيل من انفه
والاخطر ان اسرائيل التي باتت تحدد
اولويات واشنطن في منطقه الشرق الاوسط قد
تق امريكا الى حتفها على شواطئ الخليج
العربي كيف ولماذا هذا يقتضي اولا ان نعرف
دوافع الفريق الاول المتحمس لدعم اسرائيل
بهذا الشكل
المطلق الاجابه الكامله على هذا السؤال في
حلقه سابقه بعنوان لماذا يخاف الرؤساء
الامريكان من اسرائيل استاذنكم ان تعودوا
اليها حتى لا نكرر ما جاء فيها لكن اذكركم
باختصار ان هذا الدعم له عده دوافع واسباب
واحد الاعتبارات الدينيه هناك شرائح واسعه
من المسيحيين على الاقل في الغرب يؤمنون
ان وجود اسرائيل هو اراده
الهيه ببساطه هناك ما يعرف بالصهيونيه
المسيحيه الصهيونيه اليهوديه التي يعرفها
الجميع هي التشجيع على عوده اليهود الى
وطنهم التوراتي في صهيون او في
فلسطين المسيحيه الصهيونيه هو حرص
المسيحيين على عوده اليهود ايضا الى
فلسطين لان هذا من وجهه نظرهم هو شرط
اساسي لعوده المسيح للارض وبدء الخلاص
والالفيه السعيده ويعتقد هذا التيار من
المسيحيين ان عوده اليهود الى ارض الميعاد
هو تحقيق لنبوءات جاءت في الكتاب المقدس
كما يفهمونه نعوم تشومسكي المفكر الامريكي
اليهودي
الفذ يؤكد ان الصهيونيه المسيحيه قوه
جباره في السياسه الغربيه وتحديدا
بريطانيا وامريكا وهي موجوده قبل
الصهيونيه اليهوديه بوقت طويل يعني قبل ان
تتبلور فكره تيودور هيرتزل اللي هو مؤسس
حركه الصهيونيه في البحث عن وطن قومي
لليهود كانت بعض النخب المسيحيه في اوروبا
وامريكا يفكرون في ارسال اليهود الى هناك
باعتبار ان هذا شرط اساسي لعوده المسيح
كما قلت
هذه القناعات الدينيه كانت سببا اساسيا في
السياسات الداعمه لاسرائيل لكثير من
المسؤولين الكبار في الولايات المتحده مثل
الرئيس الامريكي ويلسن الذي بارك وعد بلفر
وويلسون كان مسيحيا متدينا يقرا الكتاب
المقدس كل يوم ومثل هاري ترومن الرئيس
الامريكي الذي كان اول من يعترف بدوله
اسرائيل
بالمناسبه مايك جونسون رئيس مجلس النواب
الجديد في امريكا ادلى بحوار مهم لموقع
ديلي سجنل يوم 31 اكتوبر الماضي تحدث فيه
بصراحه عن تاثير الدين على قرارات السياسه
الامريكان وكان من بين ما قاله ان دعم
اسرائيل واجب ديني واضح لكل من يؤمن
بالكتاب المقدس الذي يقول بارك الله الامه
التي تبارك اسرائيل ولعن الله الامه التي
تلعن اسرائيل ارجعوا للحوار حوار مهم يعني
عشان تفهموا الناس دي بتفكر ازاي ده
الاعتبار
الاول الاعتبار الثاني اعتبار ثقافي
المواطن الامريكي يتربى على قراءه ومشاهدت
فلاسفه وكتاب وفنانين ومدرسين يهود في
الفصل ال 25 من مذكرات اوباما الارض
الموعوده رئيس الامريكي السابق تحدث عن
مدرسيه اليهو الذين الذين اثروا فيه
ورسموا صوره افلاطونيه عن اسرائيل وتحدث
عن الكتب التي التهمها لكتاب يهود كبار
حين كان في المرحله الثانويه وهكذا ولا
تنسوا ايضا عنصر التشابه بين امريكا
واسرائيل اسرائيل مجتمع استيطاني يسعى
لبناء دولته على حساب الفلسطينيين والعرب
تماما مثل الامريكي الذي بنى دولته على
حساب من نسميهم الان بالهنود الحمر اي
المواطنين الاصليين الذين كانوا موجودين
على الاراضي
الامريكيه ثلاثه اعتبارات استراتيجيه
اسرائيل حليف قوي دعم امريكا خصوصا اثناء
الحرب البارده ثم في مقاومه الارهاب كما
تعرفه امريكا والانظمه المارقه على
الولايات المتحده في الشرق
الاوسط اربعه اعتبارات انتخابيه اي تاثير
اللوبي
اليهودي القوي الذي يستخدم امواله نفوذه
لدعم المرشح الذي ترد عنه
اسرائيل انا عاوز اديكم امثله تظهر كيف
تتضافر هذه الاعتبارات الرئيسيه الاربعه
انا بقول الرئيسيه لان في اعتبارات اخرى
غير رئيسيه يعني في اتخاذ الغرب قرارات
داعمه لاسرائيل حتى لو كانت على مصلحه
الولايات المتحده
احيانا المثال الاول هو وعد بالفر احنا
بنتكلم على وعد بالفر وبن اختصره في عباره
ا يعني جميله بتقول وعد صدر ممن لم يملك
الى من لا يستحق لكن الحقيقه قلما نتحدث
عن دوافع بريطانيا لاصدار هذا الوعد
بالمناسبه هذا الوعد صدر في مثل هذه
الايام وتحديدا في 2 نوفمبر
1917 الوعد اصدره نيابه عن الحكومه صاحبه
الجلاله وزير خارجيه بريطانيا وقتها ارثر
جيمس بالفر ولذلك سمي بوعد
بلفر الوعد خلصته وعد لليهود بوطن قومي
لهم في فلسطين هذا الوعد سيء الذكر له
اسباب متعدده اهمها السبب الرئيسي وهو
رغبه بريطانيا في استخدام قوه ونفوذ
اليهود داخل الولايات المتحده القصه
ايه باختصار شديد كانت بريطانيا في هذا
الوقت
1917 و16 و15 هي مشغوله جدا جدا في الحرب
العالميه الاولى اللي بدات في اغسطس
2014 كانت في حاجه شديده الى دعم الولايات
المتحده لها في هذه الحرب لكن التيار
السياسي السائد للنخب الامريكيه في ذلك
الوقت كان يرفض دخول الحرب ويفضل ان تناى
امريكا بنفسها عن الصراعات
الاوروبيه اللي عاوز يعرف مزيد من اجواء
الحرب العالميه الاولى
وتفاصيلها واطرافها المختلفه في حلقه
موجوده استاذنكم ان تعودوا اليها لكن من
بين القوى المعارضه لدخول امريكا الحرب
الحرب العالميه الاولى
فئتان المهاجرون الالمان والمهاجرون
اليهود او اليهود الذين يعيشون داخل
امريكا وكل له اسبابه الالمان الامريكان
اللي كان بيقدر عددهم بحوالي 20 مليون
مواطن كانوا غير راغبين في ان تخوض بلدهم
الجديد اللي هي الولايات المتحده حربا ضد
بلدهم الاصلي اللي هي المانيا الجاليه
اليهوديه كانت بتعارض ذهاب امريكا الى
الحرب لسببين واحد كثير من اثرياء اليهود
كانوا من اصول المانيه وبالتالي لهم نفس
موقف الجاليه الالمانيه اللي انا لسه
متكلم عنه والثاني ان كثير من اليهود
الاخرين بقى عامه اليهود الامريكان جاؤوا
من روسيا ومن دول اوروبا الشرقيه التي
كانت تسيطر عليها الامبراطوريه الروسيه
بعد المذابح التي وقعت لهم في هذه
الامبراطوريه الروسيه بدايه من عام
1882 ودي قصه
طويله وبالتالي ما كانوش متحمسين لفكره ان
تحارب امريكا التي انقذتهم في نفس المعسكر
مع روسيا التي
اضطهدت طبعا روسيا كانت بتحارب مع
بريطانيا وفرنسا ضد المانيا وامبراطوريه
النمسا والمجر والامبراطوريه العثمانيه ثم
اتسعت اطراف الحرب في
المعسكرين كان الهدف الرئيسي لوعد بلفور
في هذه الاجواء بالنسبه بالنسبه لبريطانيا
هو تقليل معارضه هذه الجاليه اليهوديه
لخوض امريكا الحرب الى جانبها هل كان قرار
الحرب في امريكا متروك لليهود لا لكن
بريطانيا كانت بتحاول التاثير على القرار
الامريكي بطرق مختلفه منها اغراء اليهود
بحافز وهو وعد بلفر ليضغط على حكومه
بلادهم ضمن قوى اخرى بتحاول مع القوى
الاخرى مع الالمان مع الجاليات المختلفه
الى اخره هذا هو السبب الرئيسي لصدور وعد
بلفر لكن كانت هناك اعتبارات اخرى لولاها
ما صدر هذا
الوعد اولها المسيحيه الهينه اللي انا كنت
بتكلم عليها اي قناعه نخب بريطانيه بضروره
عوده اليهود من شتاه الارض الى ارض
الميعاد رئيس وزراء بريطانيا على سبيل
المثال وقتها ديفيد لويد جورج كان من اشد
المؤمنين بهذه الفكره اثنين فهم وقدره
الكوادر اليهوديه الذين سعوا لتامين وعد
بلفر وابرزهم حييم وايزمان وناحوم
سكوف هؤلاء كانت لديهم قدره هائله للنفاد
الى دوائر صنع القرار الغربيه بسلاسه
واقناع القاض الغربيين
بقضيتهم سكوف اللي هو شخصيه مش معروفه
دلوقتي زي حيم وايزمان اللي تولى رئاسه
الدوله
الاسرائيليه ده كان احد اهم اسباب اختياره
لينوب عن الحركه الصهيونيه في اقناع
القاده الغربيين زي ما كتب احد كتاب سيرته
هو اجادته المذهله للغات الاوروبيه وكونه
كما وصف بدقه يعني اوروبيا داخليا وخارجيا
اوروبيا بالكامل
وبالتالي وغير انه عنده قدره بقى زي ما
كانوا بيقولوا للتالق في حضور شخصيات
كبيره مثل الرئيس الامريكي
والقاضيه اوروبا وبالتالي كان عنده القدره
انه يعرض قضيته بشكل لم يستطع الجانب
الاخر الذي لم يكن موجودا اصلا ان يفعله
الجانب العربي الجانب الفلسطيني
وبالمناسبه هذه نقطه مهمه جدا غائبه عنا
احد اهم نقاط ونفوذ اليهود الى الان هو
انهم هناك هو انهم جزء من هناك هم امريكان
المان روس يفهمون مجتمعاتهم جيدا ويسخرون
هذا الفهم لخدمه
اسرائيل مثال بسيط وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي في الاسابيع الماضيه تداولت
بكثير من الاعجاب لقاء او لقائي
الكوميديان المصري الساخر باسم يوسف مع
احد البرامج الامريكيه تحدث فيهما باسم عن
الظلم
الذي يلحق يلحق بالفلسطينيين يعني بدعم
امريكي باسم لم ياتي بجديد لكن كونه يجود
اللغه الانجليزيه كونه موجود هناك كونه
يعرف وسائل الاعلام هناك كونه وجها مالوفا
لهم اعطاه مزايا عن اخرين يكتفون بتفنيد
الظلم الاسرائيلي وقوه الموقف الفلسطيني
باللغه العربيه للجمهور
العربي المثال الثاني اللي عاوز اديه لكم
واللي بتتضاف في الاعتبارات الاربعه اللي
بتجعل الامريكان وغيرهم يدعمون اسرائيل
بشكل
مطلق هو اعتراف الامريكان اصلا بدوله
اسرائيل الرئيس الامريكي هاري ترومن هو
اول رئيس في العالم يعترف باسرائيل اعترف
بها بعد 11 دقيقه فقط من الاعلان عنها في
يوم 15 مايو
1948 هذا الاعتراف له قصه مثيره لا يتسع
الوقت لها وانما يكفي ان تعرفوا ان اقطاب
اداره ترومن او ومعظمهم عارضوا اعتراف
الولايات المتحده باسرائيل في ذلك الوقت
اقطاب زي مين اعترضت المخابرات الامريكيه
واعترض مجلس الامن القومي واعترض كثير من
الجنرالات الامريكان واعترضت الخارجيه
الامريكيه وعلى راس من عارضوا هذا
الاعتراف وقتها وزير خارجيه امريكا
الجنرال جورج مارشال جورج مارشال ده شخصيه
اسطوريه في السياسه الامريكيه وكان الرئيس
ترومن نفسه بيصفوا بانه اعظم امريكي على
قيد
الحياه ليه لانه كان قائد اركان الجيوش
الامريكيه اثناء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وشغل بعد ذلك منصبي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه والخارجيه الى اخره هؤلاء جميعا
كانوا يعتقدون ان الاعتراف باسرائيل من
شانه ان يؤدي لغضب عربي واسلامي يهدد
مصالح الامريكان في المنطقه اي البترول
والقواعد العسكريه ويعطي فرصه لتغلغل
الاتحاد السوفيتي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لماذا خاطر رومن واعترف باسرائيل ضاربا
بعرض الحائط اراء كل هؤلاء الاجابه محل
خلاف لكن الخلاف على ايه ايا من
الاعتبارات الثلاث الاتيه كانت المحرك
الاساسي لترومان التعاطف مع ماساه اليهود
في اوروبا بعد الهولوكوست القناعات
الدينيه لرئيس كان بيؤمن كان بيؤمن
بالانجيل طبعا وكان الانجيل هو كتابه
المفضل عندما كان طفلا ام اسباب انتخابيه
اي رغ غبته في ضمان اصوات اليهود يعني
بندور في نفس الاعتبارات الرئيسيه اللي
كانت وما زال بتدفع الامريكان الى الدعم
المطلق لاسرائيل حتى ولو كان احيانا على
حساب المصالح
الامريكيه في مقابل هذا الفريق الذي يدعم
اسرائيل بشكل اعمى هناك فريق اخر لا يعارض
اسرائيل ولكن يحذر من ان هذا الدعم يجب
انلا يضر بمصالح امريكا وهل الدعم
الامريكي اسرائيل بيضر بمصالح امريكا نعم
وبشكل متزايد واكثر مما يتخيل الكثيرون
وكثير من المؤسسات والشخصيات النافذه في
الولايات المتحده تقول ذلك لكن اصواتها لا
تسمع بالقدر الكافي بسبب غلبه التيار
الاكبر الداعم لاسرائيل بشكل مطلق اكتفي
بثلاث امثله لمؤسسات وشخصيات مهمه دقت من
عشرات السنوات وما زالت تدق نقوس الخطر
على مستقبل امريكا ومصالحها بسبب دعمها
الاعمى للدوله
العبريه نبدا بالمؤسسه العسكريه متمثله في
هيئه الاركان المشتركه للجيش الامريكي هذه
الهيئه اصدرت من عام
1945 وحتى عام
1948 ما لا يقل عن 16 تقدير موقف او تقرير
حول القضيه الفلسطينيه وكانت هذه التقارير
كاشفه جدا لما سوف يحدث على مدار عشرات
السنوات التاليه وحتى الان مثلا في اواخر
عام
1947 كتبت هيئه الاركان المشتركه ان قرار
تقسيم فلسطين اللي اصدرته الامم
المتحده اذا دعمته الولايات المتحده من
شانها ان يضر بالمصالح الاستراتيجيه
لامريكا في الشرقين الادنى والاوسط لدرجه
ان نفوذ الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
يتاكل بحيث لا يمكن الحفاظ عليه الا
بالقوه العسكريه من فضلكم ركزوا في الكلام
اللي قالته الهيئه في سنه يعني سنه
47 علشان في جنرال اخر هيقول نفس الكلام
في سنه
2010 الهيئه عادت واصدرت تقريرا اخر مهم
جدا في 31 مارس
1948 تقرير كان بعنوان متطلبات القوه
لفلسطين في تلك الورقه توقعت هيئه الاركان
المشتركه ان الاستراتيجيه الصهيونيه ست ع
الى توريط الولايات المتحده في سلسله
عمليات تتسع وتتعمق باستمرار لتحقيق اقصى
اهداف اليهود وتكهنت الهيئه ان هذه
الاهداف ستتصاعد على النحو التالي واحد
السياده اليهوديه الاوليه على جزء من
فلسطين وده حصل يعني اليهود
هيسعنا
حصل ثم سوف يسعون لتامين قبول القوى
العظمى للحق اليهودي في الهجره غير
المحدوده لفلسطين وده حصل ثم سوف يسعون
لبسط السياده اليهوديه على كامل فلسطين
وده حصل ثم توسيع ارض اسرائيل الى شرق
الاردن والى اجزاء من لبنان وسوريا وده
جاري العمل عليه الان دعونا من التاريخ
الجنرال ديفيد باتريوس اللي خدم كرئيس
للسي اي ايه وقبلها كقائد للقياده
المركزيه الامريكيه اصدر تحذير او عبر
محذرا يعني في شهاده شهيره له في مارس
2010 امام
الكونجرس تحديدا امام لجنه القوات المسلحه
بمجلس الشيوخ في جلسه ناقشه التحديات التي
تواجه الامن والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
الجنرال قال كلام كتير وقال ايه طبعا بلغه
يعني منضبطه قدر ما يستطيع ان الاعمال
العدائيه المستمره بين اسرائيل وبعد
جيرانها بتمثل تحديات واضحه لقدرتنا على
تعزيز مصالحنا في المنطقه غالبا ما تتحول
التوترات في الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه الى
اعمال عنف ومواجهات ومواجهات مسلحه واسعه
النطاق بيقول ان الصراع ده اسرائيلي
الفلسطيني بيغذي المشاعر المعاديه لامريكا
بيقول ان الغضب العربي من القضيه
الفلسطينيه يحد من قوه وعمق شراكات
الولايات المتحده مع الحكومات والشعوب
الموجوده في الم طقه ويضعف شرعيه الانظمه
المعتدله في العالم العربي وتعريف النظام
المعتدل بالنسبه للولايات المتحده هو
النظام الراغب في التعامل مع الولايات
المتحده اللي هي معظم الدول العربيه
وبيقول ان القاعده
استغلت القاعده والجماعات المسلحه كلها
استغلت هذا الغضب الشعبي لحشد الدعم لها
ويضيف انه هذا الوضع بيمنح الصراع ان هذا
الصراع بيمن نح ايران وحزب الله وحماس
نفوذا كبيرا وده حله ايه حله ان اسرائيل
تتخلى عن مطامعها في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
والاراضي العربيه العرب اضعف وهم احوج
اضعف من اسرائيل وهم احوج للسلام وتجنب
المواجهات مع اسرائيل ما يعني انهم لو
حصلوا على حقوقهم لن تكون هناك حروب ولن
تتضرر مصالح امريكا على النحو الذي فصله
الجنرال بالمناسبه هذا الجنرال تعر رد
لهجوم شديد بعد هذه الشهاده وصدفه انه خرج
من منصبه بعد منصبه كرئيس لسي اي ايه بعد
افتضاح علاقه له خارج نطاق الزواج ده طبعا
مجرد
صدفه طيب هذا عن الجنرال ديفيد بتريوس من
يقول ذلك ايضا عدد عدد من الاكاديميين
ومنهم اثنين من اهم اساتذه العلاقات
الدوليه في الولايات المتحده جون ميرشايمر
وستيفن ام وولت اللي قالوا في كتابهم اللي
انا تعرضت اليه قبل كده قبل كده زريل
اللوبي من فضلكم اقراوا الكتاب واظن ان هو
مترجم باللغه العربيه كتاب قيم جدا خلاصه
الكتاب ان تاثير اللوبي اليهودي ادى الى
تشويش فهم صانعي السياسه الامريكيه
للمصالح الحقيقيه لبلدهم في الشرق الاوسط
وان هذا اللوبي بالاضافه الى تشجيع
الولايات المتحده على دعم اسرائيل دون قيد
او شرط تقريبا لعب ادوارا رئيسيه في تشكيل
السياسه الامريكيه تجاه الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني والغزو الامريكي للعراق
والمواجهات المستمره مع سوريا وايران
ويعتقدون ان هذه السياسات لا تضر فقط
بالولايات المتحده بل انها في الواقع تضر
بمصالح اسرائيل على المدى
الطويل اوباما نفسه قال الكلام ده قاله
بشكل واضح في نفس الكتاب اللي انا اشرت
اليه منذ قليل كتاب الارض الموعوده
وتحديدا في الفصل ال 25 لما قال ان اللوبي
اليهودي او الايباك كان في الماضي يربط
دعمه لاي سياسي امريكي باستمرار المعونه
الامريكيه لاسرائيل وعرقله اي جهود
لادانته او عزل اسرائيل في مجلس الامن او
في الامم المتحده والمنظمات الدوليه
المختلفه لاحظوا ان اسرائيل بتحصل على
مليارات الدولارات الامريكيه رغم انها
واحده من اغنى دول العالم والسبب هو ضغط
اللوبي
اليهودي لكن مع توجه السياسه الاسرائيليه
لليمين ده اللي بيقول الكلام ده اوباما
تغيرت ايضا مطالب الايباك وبات يصر اعضائه
على انه لا يجب ان يكون هناك اي فارق بين
الحكومتين الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه حتى عندما تتصرف اسرائيل
بشكل يتناقض مع سياسه الولايات المتحده
وهؤلاء الذين عارضوا اسرائيل بصوت مرتفع
من السياسه الامريكان
خاطره بالحصول على لقب معادي لاسرائيل
واحتمال ان يحصل على لقب معادي للساميه
كلها ويواجه بخصم يتمتع بدعم اكبر من
الايباك في الانتخابات التاليه اي ان
الساس الامريكان يتخذون قرارات في غير
صالح امريكا احيانا بسبب ضغط اللوبي
اليهودي تعالوا نختبر كلام هؤلاء ونشوف
ماذا فعلت حرب غزه الاخيره بامريكا
كيف اثر الانحياز الامريكي الاعمى
لاسرائيل على المصالح الامريكيه اول اثار
العدوان الاسرائيلي المدعوم امريكيا على
غزه واحد هو زياده المشاعر المناهضه
والكاره لامريكا في العالم بصفه عامه وفي
منطقه الشرق الاوسط بصفه خاصه وانتعاش
التطرف الديني الذي يهدد امريكا من قال
ذلك انا لا لال الكلام ده وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه اللي اصدرت تحذيرا في 19 اكتوبر
الماضي تؤكد فيه ان هناك احتمالا متزايدا
لهجمات ارهابيه او اعمال عنف ضد المواطنين
والمصالح الامريكيه طبعا بسبب الحرب
ووزاره الامن الداخلي اللي قالت ان
الولايات المتحده اصبحت في بيئه التهديد
متزايده نتيجه الحرب ومكتب التحقيق
الفيدرالي اللي حذر من ان العديد من
المنظمات الارهابيه الاجنبيه دعت الى شن
هجمات ضد الامريكان والدول الغرب الداعمه
لاسرائيل
هذه اول نتيجه النتيجه
الثانيه انهيار خطه الاداره الامريكيه
لتشكيل الشرق الاوسط بحيث يبقى منطقه نفوذ
امريكيه مغلقه امام خصومها الصين وروسيا
وايران وجوهر هذه الخطط بيعتمد على ادماج
اسرائيل مع حلفاء امريكا العرب في مواجهه
ثلاثي الصين وروسيا وايران هذا الدمج
بتسعى اليه واشنطن بطرق متعدده ابسطها
طبعا
التطبيع واخر حلقات هذه التطبيع اقامه
علاقات بين السعوديه واسرائيل وكانت
الولايات المتحده قطعت فيه اشواط كبيره
وبعد هذا التطبيع او بالتوازي معه تاسيس
نيتو شرق اوسطي ومشروع الممر الاقتصادي
الذي يربط الهند بالخليج باوروبا عن طريق
اسرائيل الخ وده كله تحدثنا عنه قبل ذلك
كثيرا كل هذا انه انهار او على الاقل تجمد
لسنوات ثلاثه تبخرت امال امريكا منذ 2013
من ايام اوباما في التخفف من اعبائها في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط لتتفرغ لمواجهه الصين
في بحر الصين الجنوبي وروسيا في اوروبا
الشرقيه وعليها الان ان تكثف من تواجدها
العسكري في المنطقه بدلا من خفضه على حساب
مصالحها في شرق اسيا حيث يجب ان تدع عن
تايوان وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
واستراليا الخائفين من سياسات الصين
العدوانيه بالنسبه لهم وعلى حساب اوكرانيا
اللي بدات تعاني من انفضاض الدعم الامريكي
لها بعد انشغال امريكا باسرائيل بدايه من
7 اكتوبر
2023 امريكا تخسر ما هو اهم صورتها
ونفوذها امام دول الجنوب العالمي ايه دول
الجنوب العالمي نفس الاسم الذي بات شائعا
الان
لدول العالم الثالث او الدول الناميه اللي
احنا بننت مي اليها السي ان ان حصلت على
برقيه ارسلت من عدد من
السفارات العربيه الموجوده في المنطقه
لاداره بايدن بتحذر فيها من ان الدعم
الامريكي الهائل لحرب اسرائيل المدمره على
غزه يفقدنا الجمهور العربي لجيل
كامل خمسه بسبب هذا الدعم امريكي المطلق
لاسرائيل تبخرت كل جهود امريكا لشيطان
روسيا بسبب عدوانها على
اوكرانيا لشهور طويله جدا سعت امريكا
لاقناع ما يسمى بدول الجنوب العالمي اللي
هو احنا او كثير من دول العالم ببساطه بان
روسيا دوله شريره ليه لانها انتهكت
القانون الدولي بعدوانه على سياده دوله
اخرى وان التسامح في هذا العدوان سيجعل
العالم غاب لا تامن فيها اي دوله صغيره
على نفسها
نداء امريكا لكل دول العالم من اجلكم
حافظوا على النظام الدولي الحالي الذي
اقوده طبعا المبني على القوانين رولز بيست
اوردر القوانين يعني القانون
الدولي ثم جاء العدوان الاسرائيلي مجددا
على غزه بدعم امريكي فضرب كل القوانين
الدوليه بعرض الحائط ببساطه العالم بات
يرى ان ما يهم امريكا ليس الحفاظ على
القانون الدولي ولا القواعد اللي هي متفق
عليها يعني بين دول العالم ولكن الحفاظ
على رغباتها ومصالحها روسيا دوله مجرمه
لانها عدو لامريكا اسرائيل قوه خير لانها
حليف لامريكا بوتين يجب ان يمثل امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لانه نقل اطفال
اوكران لروسيا حتى تتبناهم اسر روسيه ياهو
لا يجب ان يمس بعد ان قتل حوالي 5000 طفل
في غزه ملحوظه مهمه جدا المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في مارس
2023 اصدرت امر باعتقال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين واحدى المسؤولين الروس
اللي هي المسؤوله عن مجلس حقوق الاطفال في
روسيا ايه التهمه الترحيل القصري لاطفال
من اوكرانيا الى روسيا طب الاطفال دول
اللي الروس خدوهم وفقا ل يعني
خصومهم الهدف ان هم يروحوا الى روسيا
فيمنحه الجنسيه الروسيه وتتبناه عائلات
روسيه طبعا هذه جريمه ان ثبتت يجب ان
يحاكم الرئيس الروسي وكل المسؤولين الروس
عن ذلك لكن هذه الجريمه عباره عن ترحيل
قصري لاطفال اوكران طبعا الروايه الروسيه
مختلفه لكن هناخذ بروايه محكمه العدل
الدوليه و خصوم روسيا الذين تقدموا بهذا
الملف هناخذ بروايتهم وانه هؤلاء الاطفال
اخذوا من اوكرانيا دون استشاره اهاليهم
حتى تتبناهم اسر روسيه
وترعاهم لكن نتنياهو وجنوده قتلوا نحو
5000 طفل في غزه منذ 7 اكتوبر والى الان
وطبعا هو لم يقتل اطفالا فقط هو قتل اكثر
من 14000 قتيل خلاف المصابين وخلاف
المفقودين لكن هذا لا يستحق من وجهه نظر
امريكا ان يقدم نتنياهو ولا جنرالاته ولا
مسؤوليه الى محكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هذا
هو النظام الدولي الذي تريد امريكا ان
تقنع دول العالم انه هو الافضل لها
باختصار شديد صعب جدا ان تحافظ امريكا على
مكانتها كقوه عظمى تشرف على نظام دولي
تبارك هي انتهاك قواعده بشكل يستحيل
تبريره او الدفاع عنه من اجل اسرائيل دعم
امريكا لاسرائيل بشكل مطلق واحد من اخطر
نقاط ضعف الولايات المتحده كقوه كبرى
واعداء امريكا يوظفون هذا الضعف جيدا
لافروف وزير خارجيه روسيا مثلا قال من كم
شهر الى كل ما الى كل من لا يستطيع ان
ينام بسبب انزعاجه من الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه والفضائح طبعا اللي بترت كبها
روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه يه اعطيكم
نصائح نصائح مجموعه نصائح حتى تهدوا
النصيحه الاولى تخيل ان ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا يحدث في افريقيا او في الشرق
الاوسط او ببساطه تخيل ان اوكرانيا هي
فلسطين النصيحه الثانيه تخيل ان روسيا هي
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي لن تشعر باي
قلق وسوف تنام نوما عميقا طبعا هو بيتحدث
بشكل ساخر ان لو كان ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
يقلقكم كان الاولى انه ما يحدث في فلسطين
على مدار عشرات السنوات بدعم امريكي كان
يجب ان يقلقكم اكثر الاخطر من كل ده ان
حرب غزه كان من الممكن ان تقود امريكا
لحرب واسعه مع حزب الله ثم
ايران اسرائيل سعت لتوسيع دائره الحرب
وامريكا بذلت جهدا كبيرا للسيطره على هذه
الرغبه ثلاث مسؤولين امريكان واسرائيليين
اكدوا ذلك لموقع اكسيوس و اللي قال ان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي حذر
ويعني ضغط على المسؤولين في اسرائيل بعدم
فتح جبهه مع حزب
الله امريكا في حقيقه الامر بتسيطر بصعوبه
منذ 2006 على مساعي اسرائيل لدفع امريكا
لحرب مع ايران وده خصصنا له حلقه قبل ذلك
سوف اضع لكم رابطها استاذنكم ان تعودوا
اليها لكن هذا قد لا يدوم وقد تنجح
اسرائيل فعلا في اشعال هذا الصراع الذي من
شانه ان يور امريكا في حرب قد تكتب
نهايتها كدوله عظمى اذكركم بامرين انه حتى
لو لم تقع هذه الحرب بين امريكا
يران فان اسرائيل نجحت في جعل استهداف
ايران على قمه اولويات السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه المنطق يقول ان العداء مع ايران
اولويه اسرا اسرائيليه وليست اولويه
امريكيه طبعا عكس العداء ليس الصداقه يعني
يمكن رغم التوتر والتناقضات بين ايران و
الولايات المتحده ان تكون هناك علاقه
هادئه بين امريكا وايران ببساطه الخلاف
الابرز الان بين امريكا وايران على الورق
هو البرنامج النووي الايراني ايران عاوزه
تطور قدرتها النوويه وامريكا تعتقد ان هذا
خطر لا يجب ان تسمح به طيب تمام نعوم
تشومسكي وليس انا ابدا ملحوظه وجيهه جدا
من عده شهور ايضا وصف فيها هذا الداء
لهذا السبب بانه عداوه مصطنعه لان علاج
هذه المشكله اللي هو المشكله النوويه
الايرانيه ليس ار بايران ولا حصارها ولا
فرد عقوبات عليها وانما واحد من حلين الحل
الاول تنفيذ المبادره القديمه التي تقضي
بانشاء منطقه خاليه من الاسلحه النوويه في
الشرق الاوسط والجميع ومنهم ايران يباركون
هذه المبادره لكن من يعارضها امريكا
ولماذا تعارض امريكا هذه المبادره التي
تدعم مصالحها لانها ستدفع الامريكان الى
فتح ملف الاسلحه النوويه الاسرائيليه وهي
لا تريد ان تقترب من هذا الملف
ابدا اثنين الحل بالمناسبه اسرائيل في حال
انه هذه الدول باتت لا تمتلك سلاحا نوويا
كلها عندها تفوق بالاسلحه التقليديه على
كل دول المنطقه فضلا عن ان امريكا سوف
تهرع تهرع اليها ا في اي لحظه يتم تهديدها
وطبعا يعني هتكون تحت حمايه المظله
النوويه الامريكيه والغربيه اثنين او الحل
الثاني تم تفعيله بالفعل من خلال الاتفاق
النووي الذي وقعت عليه امريكا والمجتمع
الدولي مع ايران في 2015 لكن تحت ضغط
اسرائيل بشكل رئيسي انسحبت منه الولايات
المتحده في مايو
2018 ما يعني ان مشكله امريكا الاساسيه مع
ايران والتي تضع الشرق الاوسط كله على
صفيح ساخن هي مشكله اسرائيليه وليست
امريكيه نفس الشيء بالنسبه لحماس كل ما
تريده حماس هو تنفيذ قرارات الامم المتحده
لتصفيه الاحتلال كل ما كانت تحتاجه امريكا
ان تدعم هذه القرارات التي من شانها ليس
فقط منع حروب ماساويه مثل حرب غزه الحاليه
ولكن من شانه دعم صوره امريكا ومصالحها
لكن هذا يتعارض مع رغبه اسرائيل وتحديدا
اليمين الاسرائيلي في قدم اراضي
الفلسطينيين والاستمتاع بها اسرائيل اللي
سبق لها ان جرت امريكا لغزو العراق لن
تهدا حتى تجرها مجددا لضرب ايران الحرب مع
غزه الصغيره كانت مرشحه للتوسع والاتساع
لتصبح حربا اقليميه فما بالكم بحرب مع
ايران وكله من اجل عيون اسرائيل التي
ستقود امريكا على الارجح الى نهايتها كقوه
عظمى على شواطئ الخليج العربي اشكركم والى
اللقاء